>> Ian: WE ARE DOWN TO TEN TO
SHOOT.
24 SECONDS TO PLAY.
UTAH UP BY THREE.
MITCHELL, THE CROSS.
MITCHELL, THE JUMPER.
OFF THE RIM.
REBOUNDED BY RONDO.
L.A. DOWN BY THREE.
TEN SECONDS LEFT.
LEONARD.
FOR GEORGE.
BACK FOR LEONARD.
BALL FAKE.
RUNNING OUT OF TIME.
MORRIS, ONE DRIBBLE, BLOCKED!
AND THAT WILL DO IT.
THAT'S GAME!
AND IT ENDS ON A FRENCH
MAGICIAN.
UTAH HOLDS ON AND TAKES GAME ONE
AT HOME.
>> Greg: INCREDIBLE DEFENSIVE
DISPLAY ON THAT LAST POSSESSION.
THEY WERE IN SCRAMBLE MODE.
VERY DISCIPLINED.
DIDN'T OVERREACT TO PUMP FAKES.
AND GOBERT HERE AVOIDS THE
CONTACT, STAYS WITH IT, AND THE
LONG ARM OF THE LAW DELIVERS FOR
THE JAZZ ONCE AGAIN.
>> Ian: RUDY GOBERT, THE
TWO-TIME DEFENSIVE PLAYER OF THE
YEAR.
AND HE CAN SINGLE HANDEDLY
ANCHOR YOUR DEFENSE IN THE
BIGGEST MOMENT DONOVAN
MITCHELL'S FAMILY ENJOYING A
JAZZ WIN IN A TIGHT ONE.
GAME ONE OF THE WESTERN
CONFERENCE SEMIS.
>> Greg: THAT WAS A TREAT.
THAT WAS ONE HECK OF A BALL
GAME.
GREAT INTENSITY.
AND HOW ABOUT THE FIGHT OF THE
JAZZ IN THAT SECOND HALF?